[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys where today we have over
there the lovely Trio of Anthony Steven
Joe Luna let's go baby right here at the
athletic table we have Bart Quan and
Nick dun Matthew shs we wear the same
shirt here in the Filipino side we have
me and dri
heyy why you kid me for real D little
hair little bit
that was so filipin demonetized no or
remonetized depending on the cultural
climate I think right now the more gayer
you are the lifted we become so do more
of that what about you guys every side
has to do it lifted we become join join
it let's go that's really kiss want to
save the company don't really kiss
yeah and you got matching shirts come on
Commit F's going to do
it we kiss this isn't even on patreon
this is like people get this kiss me
dude I have the power you even kiss stop
deflecting what feel a penis honestly
dude it's like you're actually gay watch
this
[__] I'm I'm super gay thep on the lips
thep this [__] guy dude I was trying
to kiss him on the lips were you yeah
but you didn't want to kiss me on the
lips I didn't know that I thought you
trying to kiss me on the cheek if you're
comfortable sexuality you should kiss
him otherwise it's a little weird that
you don't I don't like being challenged
and I have to own up to the challenge
okay I'm G cuz I won't do
it didn't do it he didn't even do it he
didn't do it he did movie Magic no he
did movie Magic where with the nose
movie Magic he like this oh my God oh my
God that softcore porn that was I'm
horny so that's a good way to start hey
thanks man thanks for the support it
just it just basil the ledge dude I did
it it's just little BOS between
boys BOS with the boys you some BOS it's
been like a couple of years since we'
seen you man I know it's been forever I
know what's different and a welcome back
kiss is like the best way com back
sounds good when were you going to
compliment us on our cool tattoos right
now uh first off did you see it are they
shameful matching tattoos show them up
close way it looks likeing your leg oh
that's right did you see
his yeah y legit no I got to take my
pants off take your pants off I want to
show that you're down no the legs are
too tight it doesn't roll up so you got
to roll down baby legit
bleeding Ro Shack
dude where you
at damn hella clean do you think this
makes us yeah yo what's up that's pretty
girthy y yo that's legit what's that do
you think this makes us more legit or
less legit if you don't get a tattoo I
don't think you're legit and Andor kiss
you what about I have my own matching
tattoo one wasn't enough I'll take two
what was that you have two cuz he had
the original damn original one and he
had to get another one so he I didn't
get one whenever one got one so I just
got the the exact same one so what is it
going to take for the third leg to get I
have no idea none of real estate in that
one I think we're done making not enough
real estate you're so stupid be honest
be honest what do you think of these
shirts uh I feel left out but it's cool
oh oh wait wait fear everyone care oh
damn that's our merch these are the
signs it it it's debuting a first week
of October nonch saying fear everyone
like that's an okay statement a great
statement keeps you humble you know
pretty badass huh yeah I love Anthony
it's like it's like kjas but the
opposite thank
you you know it's a weird eror for me
I'm very rebellious opposite of the
kindas though he's the Loose Cannon of
kindas all fear none this is fear
everyone yeah we don't even respect
respect no one respect is not even on
the table so then if you are afraid of
everyone and then if you're not afraid
of anyone through kenas in the middle
does that mean you're a normal person it
means I respect little bit scared myself
at the same time what would Ken just
think of these shirts if you wear them
to like rehearsal and stuff and they're
all wearing the opposite thing I think
if they don't pay attention they might
be like oh is that a new kindas
shirt
right why do a lot of people want the
model of not being afraid cuz remember
that brand no fear I thought that was so
cool a very '90s sentiment it was really
yeah it was cool to not be afraid of the
'90s it's probably because everybody
actually is afraid so then you try to
put on this Mantra of no fear to either
to remind yourself or to like that's so
whack compensate it's like the opposite
but today it's all about being real Max
being scared it's all about not being
too scared to admit you're
afraid po thinking all like being afraid
scared hey if you fear everyone then you
have no one left to
fear like like the [__] ceiling has
the answer like it's up there it's
written up there too poetic for me it
sounds good all right condense this okay
I think the the appropriate approach is
I am afraid but I'mma do it anyway
what dides that say isn't that just
courage exactly what you said I think I
think that's courage isn't it yeah but
courage sounds too cool the thing about
careful boys here is we got real careful
right and to be careful you have to be
afraid of literally everybody and
everything that's true you got to be
like a prey animal don't say that don't
say that we're going to get cancelled
you got to be bottom of Fawn in the
savannah maybe we should be called
cancelled boys cancelled no that's not a
good sound like being proud of going
against the dumbest men on Earth
spell in correctly Gio called us the
dumbest men on Earth for getting us or
no be just D dumbest d u m m e s d
dumbest no T man on Earth Dum with a z
at the end so sad so you just moved
right I did from where from where to
where 8 minutes away I went from the
valley to the valley uh went from
Sherman Oaks is it a little bit of a
culture
shock it's a little white like a lot
more white people it's kind of nice you
have sh not
and it's pretty safe wait didn't go from
white to white they don't feel safe
what's that like Sherman Oaks isn't
white I thought it was white to white ah
it's just a little bit more grass so I
can't see exactly but there's definitely
more Asians Wasing oh there's more
Asians we my my neighbors but I only
know like one of them in Ino there's
Asians no in SHO Ino used to be hella
Mexican it's not anymore not anymore
fool I follow a bunch of real estate
agents out there and then they have hell
nice houses in Ino yeah but everything
in Ino right now is like getting robbed
right now really yeah we moved at like
the wrong time is it because they know
where people with money Liv I think so
and it's also like in the flatter
grounds like the flatter part so it's
not as many like calories burnt to get
to the house as opposed to the hills
that's a huge thing robbers don't want
to burn calories to much that is true no
you don't want why you're already caring
something heavy is too much true she
just put pull-up bars in front of your
house and like [__] get in there so as a
as a former Nevada resident do you feel
like you could ever return to a place
like that in your life you liveed in
Nevada yeah yeah I did I used to uh
seeing how I'm outnumbered from nevadans
right now I'm going to go ahead and say
yeah I missed it a lot and I want to
move back no but but where but where I
lived there for about 2 years where
exactly Henderson Seven Hills oh that's
why you didn't like
Nevada it's like the enino of Nevada
Seven Hills is cool what's wrong with
Seven Hills yeah I I mean that it's
almost like a gated space that nobody
else can enter yeah yeah it was it was
nice is it in a lot of Seven Hills
neighborhoods a lot of them are like
that a lot of them are pretty balling
doesn't SEL we we lived in the that part
but the opposite the not Ballin yeah
like we lived in like the just barely
made it oh what was your what was your
experience like when you were living in
uh it was YouTube life so yeah that's
when it was like power too to just work
all day I remember living oh you went
there with Ryan yeah yeah oh you were
living with Ryan no I wasn't but he was
like just a few like miles away right it
was like when all like all of the guys
that worked for him and they're all from
originally the High School dance team so
we all kind of like lived in the same I
see so it was like a group thing to get
go together and then you were just like
I can't do this [__] yeah the real truth
is I didn't want to like lose the
collaboration with Ryan cuz he was
leaving and I was like I need these
followers so I just moved over there
just straight up and then he got annoyed
by me and he found out within 6 months
and I was like [__] I already bought a
house here and I had to wait another
year and a half to move back it's uh the
truth shall set you
free so you got kicked out of the Ryan
hega group no no I'm like the only one
still repping yeah yeah what about
Victor what where where is he wait is
that I think Anthony knows was it yam
yam F no cuz we did a it was ytf ytf
yeah yeah you offend me you offend my
mother is that what yam yam F was it was
yeah Justin Lynn was doing yeah but then
I thought Ryan did something with yam
yam too cuz we did a video with yam yam
he was part he was part like of the I
don't want to say I don't know leaders
or whatever the but it was him Abdul
Khan and Justin Lynn yeah and then Ryan
left that explain what that was again
what is yum yum f again it was like
those remember those YouTube like in
what 20 they call them vertical yeah
2011 like YouTube gave out like a100
million to a bunch of companies to start
YouTube channels yes and then like 5%
after the first year yeah it was like
Phil and the Fine Brothers made it and
like everyone else got wrecked basically
yeah everybody got I mean they basically
just yeah wasted a lot of money but they
reup again
I think like like another 5 million to
each of the companies like only 5% out
of the all the companies made it YF was
one of them but once Ryan left ytf La me
and everything else uh everything fell
apart but YF actually would have got
another budget wow damn dude what an era
they were just giv money away huh that
was crazy it was very nice for we didn't
get [__] give me
[__] actually in they never hooked up
just kidding what the freak I never got
that they got like Donna like a million
dollars just to do a YouTube channel I'm
like no one gives a [__] about Madonna's
YouTube that drove me crazy cuz they
actually did that same thing with Sarah
Silverman's come bunch of and I was like
dude these people this is the least
amount of money they make they're not
going to give a [__] they took your
money and they're just like giving it to
their friend to write for them for a
year something like that J right my
buddy was was head of jash for a while
it was they were burning cash just bur
remember when they tried to interview
nor McDonald and he just ripped on jash
so hard I was like I don't like like
Josh now yeah yeah it's funny how that
works right whatever he says someone is
that cool you'll just immediately jump
on yeah because all he asked was like
what is it exactly and they couldn't
explain it and he was like yeah I'm not
a fan
now I don't know who Josh is but I was
always surprised that they never hook up
JK cuz you guys have been in the game
since what first JK's never gotten like
an actual like hand they don't even know
that we exist we don't go we don't get
invites to [__] gold house or invites
to any of the [__] where people are
someone who's been to gold house I'm
telling you right now though you don't
want to bring you don't want to go it's
it's I'll just say this like maybe it's
cuz I'm Filipino but I just I don't know
I didn't get it like here here's the
thing the whole gold house or like I
guess what was it cape and like the
Asian group like Asian Excellence gay
for like for a year for a year I got
invited once a month to this Asian meet
up at what was it uh HomeTown Buffet
what right Hometown buff up with like
like that's not classy so for me I was
hyped for me me I was hyped but I didn't
know for the longest time like that was
the joke a bunch of Rich dudes going to
Hometown Buffet yeah yeah yeah and I'm
sitting here like having a blast like
enjoying all the things you it's like
fancy food yeah yeah and then I also
never had steak before so we went to
this like steak place like magic castle
and I ordered my steak wrong cuz it's
like back in the day it was like my mom
overcooked it so you just throw ketchup
and barbecue sauce on it but then like I
ordered M I was like I don't know well
done I didn't know how to eat it I was
stupid and so they just all like
destroyed me not all I can't say all of
them but majority the dudes in this
Asian cult group like snobby yeah but I
didn't know any better and I was just
like okay I feel uh very stupid but I'm
like very grateful and also is there
catchup to go along with my steak and uh
yeah I just felt like I yeah I don't I
don't really know I can't say everybody
is treated or treats people like that
but I don't think you guys are missing
out on it but that was your experience
yeah a little bit like corrective
bowling like remember when you when
there's all this Asian Excellence but
then you put all just different Asians
in the same room you really see the
picking order and you're like hey most
of those things to me the Asian
Excellence thing is just Chinese
American they call it Asian thing but
it's all just Chinese
people and
Etc oh yeah I guess we YouTubers most of
them are Chinese all the tuber stuff is
so nerdy and lame anyway and I don't
mean nerdy in a bad way I mean like it's
Tu nerdy no Tu nerdy all talking about
the algorithm and [__] and like [__]
talking about how to game thumbnails and
like it is just so [__] boring and
and they're and they're all the it's all
like immediately everyone like flocks
like you just threw bird seed down to
like the person with the most numbers
and then everyone just like orbits them
the whole time and like basically sucks
their dick the entire time to try feel
attacked right now get in vids no I'm I
feel like I'm learning oh you were there
oh I'm sure you know in in he's group
you know there were people doing that
yeah in whf it was massively different
whf was definitely like I think most of
us didn't know how to spell algorithm
except for Ryan when you go to like a
place that's like one of those tuber oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah like a YouTube yeah
yeah yeah you loved those remember I did
I had a blast but I think the thing is I
was still like the butt of the joke cuz
I didn't go for those reasons I just
like getting to know people and hanging
out like a high school or something no
he he used to make me go with them all
the time because shit's so boring
remember we would go to these [__]
whack ass red carpets and you would say
all wrong info to the [__] interview
they're like what website can we see one
and he's all oh r d
tube.com because they don't check it
anyway need like that's how you
algorithm but he would give like hella
wrong info and then walk away and just
laughing about it yeah anyways that's
how we start this off Mo it man I don't
think we did anything right business Le
but it just worked but what do you think
business thing though is that they don't
they truly don't know that JK exists
because we get away with so many rule
violations it's like kind of insane
that's true or my channel got [__]
wrecked just for me doing like like some
runchy videos no question we basically
say the raunchiest things here and we
don't get touched it's kind of nice
coasting think people want that deep
down inside and they also need it and
it's a rare group that actually does it
and you guys are the ones that people
love for we're also not saying it on
purpose like if that it just happens to
be that it is that also why JK is not
going to get like funding or invited to
places because you just say we just say
what do you think that's the reason
though like what's the no I don't think
we socialize enough cuz I we we used to
get invited but I think like when you
and I think we do get the emails to be
honest we have so many emails that weow
overon they've been inviting you every
year the first like we've got we've
gotten gold house like what in invite
invites which you guys don't go you
streaming never other things but there
has been time and then when we do go to
like VidCon and all that like we don't
we don't play the game you know like
there's the there there's the there's a
networking game and all that stuff right
and then like I'll go there and then
people are like all right we got to
strategize with this person they got 5
million subs and I'm I'm just like yo
this guy he's got 10,000 Subs but he's
hilarious and he can't I can't stop
laughing at him hey come have lunch with
us so we're just gravitating toward
people that we just like and I think
we've always been our own insulated
World we're like even if we do get
invited check your email yeah that's the
other thing too is like we do get
invited we just don't [__] go we want
to be in to say no I think that's the
whole thing that's the main thing cuz I
don't think I've seen the amount of
invites match the number of events that
happen like if there's 20 events I see
20 emails I only see like one or two a
year well luckily we just told everybody
that we want to be invited to say no
can't wait for all of those to be
rolling in
now I'm going to say yes this time and
also we don't socialize in network the
way they do you know what that is true
we we sit here and we go we're too
extreme they're never going to invite us
and all [__] but we just don't check our
email victim blame ourselves yeah well
as our you know prestigious leaders Joe
bar we need you to go [__] suck some
dick out there to get us invited to
places you I want to go to red carpets
I've never been to Red Carpet before me
too how many hand jobs you have to give
to get on a red carpet yeah how many one
I have to start with the email first I
don't even know start with the email I
don't even know I don't even know where
the dicks are to Jack to Jack them off
do you even know what your guys' email
is yeah yeah what is it it's probably
like has just King films in there
somewhere
business maybe business at just
kiding I never forget Nikki um got
invited to this like Hillary Clinton
thing back in the 2016 election cycle
and it was like come meet Hillary and
like do a a Q&A or whatever and then I
was like of course they don't want me
there I'm too much [__] truth teller
and [__] like that I'd probably I'd
probably be asking all kinds of
questions and [__] like that right so
then she goes to this thing she gets a
selfie with Hillary and all that stuff
and they curate everything they don't
let anyone ask any interest questions at
all it's just like fandom suery like as
a first woman as the first woman having
a vagina so what's that like so then I I
uh first question 6 months later I
checked my email cuz I have a joke with
myself that I only check my business
email every once a year cuz it's called
doll doll bills more money problems
gmail.com what the so then I checked my
I checked it and I got an invite for the
same [__] thing with Hillary so they
didn't give a [__] about me and they
just wanted me there to take a selfie
with her same thing so so did you take
it
6 months later how would I go but I did
I did take a emotional hit like a little
pride hit you know what does break my
heart though beyond all those stupid ass
gas and [__] is we've had opportunities
to speak with three different
presidential candidates to come here we
have a very close friend that's already
met with certain and then they they they
mentioned us they even put in a good
word one was Robert F Kennedy my friend
went hiking with them what did he say
he's not down to come he gave him all
the information all that stuff and he
said he got ghosted there was good old
Andrew Yang we were talking to his
team guess what happened they they
watched an example they probably did
they actually watched but the thing is
Robert F Kennedy on [__] like nek
boys and [__] well that's their numbers
are way [__] massively higher but are
they more runchy than us no they're
actually not yeah they're actually
pretty tame so basically they're totally
different and better
you know what you know where we [__]
up they probably go you know we can't
have Robert F Kennedy answering if he
would rather [__] his mom or his dad why
not the nek boys don't ask that we
haven't asked that in a long time but I
think also if you say anything about
China in general nek Boys Don't Touch
China we don't say [__] China anymore we
don't have to say that we could just
just any discussion at all anymore any
opinion like we don't say anything about
China hey D would you rather [__] your
dad or your mom if I had to choose well
like four dads which one does it matter
which one biological the one that you
you feel that is your most dad I would
probably have to go with my dad then cuz
I think his booty might be a little
cleaner he washes his mom's booty maybe
Rob or Pete uh Rob IID go rob oh OG dad
Filipino so yeah yeah so like just in
case we both see our things think the
Filipino ass is cleaner than the
Mexicans this Filipino one
is yeah it's clean it's pretty clean he
knows how he talking about he's talking
we should just put like a little super
thing he's talking about his dad's ass
how come we got meet so many Papas oh
cuz my mom was getting busy and she
couldn't make a decision Oh I thought
you had two gay dads couples two gay dad
in that world I'm kind of excited to
hear how that turned out in your brain
gay dad couples cuz you're from
NorCal what does that mean people in
ready all check this out it's simple all
right check it out he grew up in San
Francisco he got adopted by a gay couple
they [__] break up
and now they get with another gay dude
four dads four dads that that's good
math it worked out and then you buy a
plane sound like a script
doctor